[Musique]
bonjour jean maurice ripert bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous on va parler de
la chine ce pays d'où est parti le coved
19 ce pays que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous étiez ambassadeur de france
à pékin jusqu'à ce jour jamais bien la
chine je la connais un peu quelque chose
me dit que vous la connaissez quand même
et elle renforcée ou affaiblis avec
cette crise sanitaire c'est la grande
question alors on va partir de la
situation dans le pays est ce que la vie
a changé pour les chinois depuis cette
crise du coronavirus on s'attendait
plutôt à un rebond rapide de l'économie
ça n'est pas le cas
oui alors vous avez raison
le premier facteur de changement
immédiatement identifiable c'est la très
grave crise économique comme la chine
elle n'a pas commencé que l'épidémie du
coronavirus un déjà en 2018 puis en 2019
le rythme de la croissance avait ralenti
les institutions internationales
qu'angers est estimé la croissance entre
4 et 5% ce qui pour la chine je sais que
pour nous ce serait un miracle mais pour
lâcher ne savait pas c'est évidemment et
c'est notamment pour la création
d'emplois et la montée en gamme de
l'économie chinoise donc le
ralentissement économique était déjà
était déjà là et en particulier à
l'épuisement du modèle de développement
chinois du mal à s'adapter avec la crise
sanitaire à nouveau cap a été franchi et
la chine a reconnu qu'elle serait
qu'elle était en récession puisque l
annonce un chiffre de croissance de
moins c'est pour ça donc la chine comme
tous les pays du monde est atteinte à
part la craie du coronavirus certains on
pensait que la chine ne repartirai plus
vite ce qui était une erreur parce que
c'était le modèle que nous avions en
tête c'était le modèle la chine usine du
monde mais la demande s'étant effondrés
partout dans le monde
là le fonctionnement économique chinois
on est évidemment perturbé la deuxième
chose qui à mon avis a changé et va
changer les contacts que j'ai avec des
amis chinois me le font penser c'est que
le système est un système autoritaire
est en train de ces exagérations eux
mêmes de se caricaturer lui-même on a vu
au début de la pandémie
premier réflexe du régime communiste
chinois c'est de nier la réalité et pour
la nier aux yeux du monde on arrête on
enferme et on empêche les lanceurs
d'alert de lancer leur alerte pour vous
jean maurice ripert n'y a aucun doute la
chine le régime de pékin a menti sur
l'ampleur de l'épidémie au départ le le
régime de la chine à l'origine à nier
l'ampleur du phénomène peut être at il
eu du mal à les valves et lui-même il
faut comprendre comment fonctionne le
système chinois l'état partie chez loin
la chine est un pays puissant la
deuxième économie du monde ça ne veut
pas dire que l'état fonctionne de la
même façon chez nous l'état à mon avis
en chine est profondément
dysfonctionnelle
la chine est un pays gigantesque qui
fonctionne à travers des responsables de
districts de quartier de district de
mairie de région doublé par des
représentants du parti communiste à tous
ces niveaux pour téléphoner à pékin ou à
la capitale régionale puis à pékin en
disant c'est une catastrophe
j'ai des milliers de gens qui viennent
d'être victime du coronavirus il faut du
courage dans un système extrêmement
autoritaire où on est punis en
permanence et où j'ai gouverner par la
peur il faut quand même dire les choses
clairement eh bien ça ne se produit pas
on y ont réagi comme on peut donc au
début probablement
sous-évaluation de la réalité puis
probablement dans un deuxième temps
mensonge par omission on sait que la
chine n'a pas transmis à l oms
toutes les données en sa possession
aussi rapidement qu'elles auraient dû
tout le monde sait que l'épidémie a
commencé vers la mi-novembre c'est
seulement en janvier que l' alerte
générale a été lancé il y a eu
certainement dissimulation sur l'ampleur
d'où la rapidité de la propagation donc
c'est vrai les autorités chinoises sont
de mon point de vue je pars le petit
personnel partiellement responsable de
la rapidité du développement de la
pandémie
vous faites confiance à cette enquête
qui a été ouverte
sur l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé dont on sait que voilà la chine
est très est très investi très présente
dans cette organisation est ce que vous
voyez qu'on aura la vérité pourquoi pas
un jour voir pékin rendre des comptes je
ne sais pas si on aura la vérité parce
que je ne sais pas s'il ya une vérité
mais je crois qu'il faut choisir on ne
peut pas être contre tout si on trouve
un charme de grandes puissances pas
seulement la chine se comporte de
manière hégémonique de temps en temps
alors il faut faire confiance au système
multilatéral les états unanime de la
chine a été obligé de suivre le
mouvement ont décidé de mener une
enquête indépendante sur l'ensemble des
dysfonctionnements parce que il y en a
peut-être d'autres que ses difficultés
ses dissimulations chinoise originel il
faut faire confiance à cette institution
cette institution ce sont des états
alors c'est vrai que l'influencé
chinoise est importante la chine a fait
élire par les moyens traditionnels
chinois le représentant actuelle ça veut
pas dire que c'est un mauvais médecin ça
veut dire qu'il est sous pression il n'y
a aucun doute là dessus mais l'om est ce
ce sont des milliers d'experts français
américains belges australiens néo
zélandaise du d'afrique à tous ces gens
auraient pu probablement aussi se
comporter différemment donc il est
important que ce soit toute
l'institution qu'ils soient mises en
cause sinon une éventuelle mise en cause
de la chine ne serait pas crédible je
voudrais vous ramener à un petit peu
plus en arrière on est le 10 mars à one
shipping triomphalement annonce à son
peuple d'une certaine manière que c'en
est fini de l'épidémie en chine qu'elle
a été maîtrisé et puis c'est c'est le
début de ce qu'on a appelé la diplomatie
du masque là les chinois n'ont plus que
ton bienveillant et des alliés partout
en tout cas dans les pays qui souffrent
de l'épidémie distribuer en vendant des
tonnes et des tonnes de masques c'est
quoi cette diplomatie là est ce que
c'était nouveau et est pourquoi dans
quel intérêt ah qu'est ce que cherchait
pékin en faisant sa diplomatie du
sourire ce n'est pas nouveau dans
l'empiré du milieu
la bataille des mots est important sur
la scène internationale le problème des
masques il a été parfaitement compris je
crois que les chinois se sont rendu
compte très vite quand même que tout le
monde s'était rendu compte qu'il y avait
eu un problème au début de l'épidémie et
la chine avait besoin passez moi
l'expression de se racheter il se trouve
que la chine par l'ampleur de la
catastrophe probable qu'à provoquer lé
coville 19 en chine pas seulement un
moral mais sur l'ensemble du territoire
à 2 fait assécher les marchés du masque
parce qu'elle en avait besoin et elle
s'est donc retrouvé quasiment l'unique
producteur au monde de masques dans des
quantités suffisantes pour aider les
états qui n'en avaient pas assez elle
s'en procurer alors elle a pu en fournir
très rapidement cette diplomatie elle a
énormément agacé l'occident est
particulièrement donald trump qui n'a
pas hésité à parler d'un virus chinois
et qui a immédiatement retiré son
soutien de l' oms
est-ce qu'on va vers une forme de guerre
froide entre les états ou de mort sur le
chinois le les virus comme vous le savez
le sera ce h5 iéna maintenant que 8,19
son nez c'est vrai sur des marchés liés
à la consommation de certains animaux ce
qu'on peut quand même reproché à la
chine c'est pas de sa faute bien entendu
sauf que la lutte contre la consommation
de ces produits là mais sur le marché
tout le monde sait il suffit de se
promener dans les petites villes
chinoises pour savoir que partout on
continue à manger du singe du chien du
serpent du congo là tout ce que vous
voudrez donc il n'y a pas eu cette
capacité de l'état chinois à contrôler
ça c'est quand même un problème
cela dit c'est pas si loin parce qu'il
est né en chine malheureusement
je ne crois pas qu'on soit on se dirige
dans une deuxième guerre froide parce
que c'était pas ça la guerre froide la
guerre froide c'était deux blocs unis
chacun derrière un pays qui les menait
la rue c'est l'urss la russie les états
unis et qui s'affrontaient pour des
gains géostratégique ça n'est pas le cas
on est malheureusement aujourd'hui dans
une situation
où certains des clients dire on a voulu
un monde multipolaire on a un monde
multipolaire mais on appris de
multilatéralisme c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas de moyens de régulation de ce monde
multipolaire et l'europe est bien le rsa
la chine change de ton également oui
mais l'europe entre dans une ère de
tension très forte entre la chine et les
états unis en a eu d'autres et l'europe
d'une certaine manière ne veut plus
jouer les naïfs vis-à-vis de pékin oui
je tuerai qu'il est en moi j'ai aussi
travaillé pour l'union européenne je
tiens ma seule l'union européenne je
crois que on a trop longtemps
sous-estimé la puissance que représente
l europe l'europe est une puissance non
militaire mais c'est une puissance et
parmi les quatre grands blocs de quatre
grands états les etats-unis la chine la
russie et l'europe moi je crois que
l'europe a des moyens parfaitement se
défend justement parce que nous ne
sommes pas hégémonique nous n'avons rien
nous ne cherchons pas des gains
contrairement à d'autres et surtout nous
sommes attachés au fonctionnement du
système multilatéral parce que nous en
avons besoin plus que les autres nous
sommes entendus de la chine le grand
marché intérieur européen la chine en a
besoin alors il faut entre guillemets
négocier accès des chinois pour dérocher
loi on n'est pas américain on ne
pratique pas la menace ont pratiquement
les mesures de rétorsion mais ça veut
pas dire en effet que nous sommes naïfs
la diplomatie du paillasson ça ne marche
pas avec des grandes puissances
effectivement on se rend compte que
cette diplomatie du masque elle n'a pas
duré très longtemps pékin au fond alors
qu'on avait l'impression que dans cette
crise avait envie de redorer un peu son
image a décidé durcir le ton avec ce
projet de loi sécuritaire qui revient
complètement sur sept jours voilà à hong
kong sur cette idée de un état de deux
systèmes et qui décide de passer un
texte évidemment qui remet en cause la
liberté on sait ce qu'on a appelé la
diplomatie des loups guerrier pékin a
demandé à ses ambassadeurs de hausser le
ton donc la diplomatie chinoise a testé
et probablement elle a constaté que ça
ne marchait pas et que voilà on y
compris en europe on en avait peut-être
un petit peu assez de se faire
traiter par dessus la jambe
ce que je crains c'est que
à cause de tout cela
le clan des durs passez moi l'expression
je ne sais pas comment l'exprimer les
soutiens de 6 jean ping d'un ultra
nationalisme sourcilleux d'un retour aux
sources du maoïsme la fin de la
direction collective
la fin des organes dirigeants si jean à
réformer la constitution et la charte du
parti avec deux effets un il est
président à vie de sa pensée figure dans
la constitution et dans la charte du
parti pour 6 jean ping l'une de ses
toutes premières priorités c'était le
retour de taiwan et de hong kong à la
mère patrie à cause de ce qui s'est
passé du durcissement du ton de la
montée du régime autoritaire du contrôle
de la population
taïwan a voté en janvier dernier en
réalisant la présidente indépendantiste
qui a obtenu ou également le
renouvellement de sa majorité au
parlement taïwanais qui est une
démocratie et à hong kong 7 millions de
gens sont descendus dans la rue et vous
avez eu aux élections locales 85 %
d'élues pro démocratie c'est-à-dire
antimissile jiping donc c'est un échec
et malheureusement comme souvent en
chine au lieu de chercher une autre
solution on enfonce le clou on va
toujours plus loin en priant si j'ose
dire pour ça se passe bien mais cette
fois ci je crains que ça se passe mal le
parti communiste chinois s'apprêtent à
fêter son centième anniversaire l'année
prochaine à vous entendre
rien ne change au contraire je parlais
des personnels c'est mon analyse je
pense que les choses changent on un jour
n'oubliez pas que la génération actuelle
les millénium actuelle en chine sont les
enfants qui ont connu à travers leurs
parents la révolution culturelle c'est
extrêmement important culturellement
parce que ils sont élevées dans la peur
et n'oubliez pas également que le régime
est mis en place un système absolument
hallucinant qui s'appelle le crédit
social tout passe par votre téléphone
tout le monde est fasciné par ça quand
je vois qu'en france on s'inquiète quand
on vous demande de brancher votre
bluetooth en chine vous ne pouvez plus
rien faire autrement que par votre
téléphone c'est à dire sous le contrôle
de la police politique chinoise dont
vous êtes sous le contrôle permanent du
pouvoir et il ya des sanctions de
permanente donc toute forme de
contre-pouvoir est impossible elle est
impossible sauf comme toujours dans ces
régimes à l'intérieur
de la nomenclatura rouge si je peux
utiliser ce mot russe il faut espérer
que les libéraux les plus modérés
finiront par l'emporter ça prendra
probablement du temps alors la chine
affaiblir ou renforcée finalement à
l'issue du coronavirus le chedd est
affaibli comme tous les pays du monde la
façon dont la chine en sortira dépendra
beaucoup de la façon dont les dirigeants
comprendront ou pas que les choses vont
changer et qu'il va falloir que la chine
change comme nous tous le comportement
individuel le comportement collectif la
chaîne a besoin d'un monde
multilatéraliser comme les autres il
faut qu'elle accepte qu'elle en tire les
conséquences merci beaucoup jean maurice
ripert d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci m
m